[Music]
[Applause]
when i get about two seconds to sit down
that's where i'm gonna i'm gonna sit
there and i'm gonna go
god how about this one by hey man alive
it's always just a little bit awkward
when pat puts it up like that man
because you it just you know you're open
but you don't know how open you are and
our goal from the beginning of the
season was to win the super bowl not to
get to it the way it ended you know it
doesn't sit right with me
a chippy and ticky tacky got and
i'm disappointed myself it's just hard
to
have a lot to say about something that
you were not prepared for
getting to the super bowl wasn't what
our goal is our goal is to win it you
know now home super bowl for the first
time in nfl history i think puts a lot
of cool things in perspective
it's a grind just to get to this point
and that makes the finality of it all
kind of hits you like a ton of bricks
that's why it's a
gutting feeling
in your stomach
welcome to safety blitz starring the
two-time super bowl champ at rodney
harrison jack collins collinsworth so
rod the super bowl is set as you sat on
your couch yesterday with this super
bowl now set in motion what were some of
your thoughts tom brady 10 super bowls
since being a sixth round draft pick
back in 2000 what was going through your
head man i texted a few of my former
teammates and i said can you believe
this dude at 43 years old he's going
back to the super bowl and i looked down
on my phone i probably had like 10
messages myself and everybody just
completely awestruck about tom brady but
we we shouldn't really be we really
shouldn't be like surprised because tom
does such a wonderful job of preparing
himself mentally taking care of his body
physically and like the mental toughness
that tom brady has it's just absolutely
incredible but i was just stunned like
you probably were jack
it for me it was just kind of a
realization of what the nfl has now
become it's been this slow transition
into full offensive football they've
been doing all these rules for years now
making it harder and harder on the
defensive side of the ball trying to go
all offense all quarterbacks and now
these best quarterbacks mahomes tom
brady have just built dream team rosters
it's like the nba almost how many great
players can you accumulate that can just
dominate one-on-one match-ups on the
outside and now both of these teams have
just run right through the nfl and
straight up to the super bowl and you
have the quarterback who has gone to 10
and tom brady 10 super bowls and then
you have going up against the other
quarterback who may be the only player
in the history of football they could
possibly make it to 11. so that to me is
what it's become you have two minds that
can do anything two talents at the
quarterback position that could do
anything and then they've just loaded up
offenses around them and that's what the
nfl at the top shelf is right now and
nobody else even the bills who are by
far the second best team in the afc they
just can't compete
well just think if you were drew brees
matt ryan and teddy bridgewater and tom
brady comes into your division the very
first year and no he doesn't win the
division he's heading to the super bowl
imagine how that makes those guys feel
that's just how good tom brady is and i
don't want to hear people trying to
compare is it belichick is it brady
bella belichick is not the same guy
without tom brady and tom brady's not
the same player without coach belichick
let's nip that in the bud both of them
are great and both of them deserve to be
considered the goat at what they do but
yeah you talk about this super bowl man
this is absolutely incredible to see the
next generation of the great patrick
mahomes you know playing against tom
brady and one thing about tom brady tom
brady is a thug i said this before he he
doesn't care about who you are he wants
to beat you and trust me he wants to
compete against patrick mahomes and and
he wants to make sure that the kansas
city chiefs don't they're not the first
team to go back to back since our
patriots in 03 and 04 so i'm really
excited about this super bowl jack
[Music]
let's get into some of these games from
yesterday i want to hit on the bucks
defense because they're going up against
the mvp it's one of the great offenses
in football and aaron rodgers hasn't
played this well really in his career
todd bowles had this buck's defense
flying around and david bachdiori the
absence of him at left tackle you saw it
it just showed up and nobody could
protect aaron's blindside and rarely do
you see a rod under pressure like that
taking big hits like that genuinely
uncomfortable throughout a game like he
was yesterday what did you think of the
inability to protect or maybe just what
todd bowles was able to do in terms of
getting pressure on aaron rodgers
yeah it was definitely about todd bowles
and i thought he called an incredible
game i mean he switched it up sometimes
it was four-man on rushes sometimes
there's a lot of five-man pressures he
went man-to-man he went zone and
safeties even though he were playing he
was basically playing with two backup
safeties because both his safeties were
hurt um
they did a wonderful job of disguise and
they were physical they didn't miss a
lot of tackles i i thought the defense
was flying around and devin white is
for the life of me i don't understand
how could this guy not be voted to the
all-pro team i mean nine and nine sacks
or whatever 140 50 tackles just all over
the field and you saw his impact when he
came back how everyone else is impacted
you saw jpp and shaquille barrett just
giving him a hard time and you look at
aaron rodgers aaron rodgers looked
confused he looked hesitant all year
we've seen aaron rodgers drop back with
the utmost confidence i didn't see that
these guys were absolutely outstanding
shaquille gear shaquille barrett he's
going to set up for a huge payday jason
pierre-paul he was outstanding and this
is the same pressure that they're going
to need against patrick mahomes because
he's a guy that can move he's dynamic
either throw the ball down the field he
can do absolutely everything with the
football
anytime defensively you can shut down
the run i mean green bay has three great
running backs three really great running
backs uh aj aj dillon who we had seen
coming from the end of the year we
thought
yeah we thought when you got into this
bad weather football that dylan might
have the ability to take over some of
these games in the power running game
not one of those three stud running
backs were over 30 yards in this game
and then you supplement with that with
what they were able to do getting
pressure on aaron rodgers it's a wonder
that they were even able to score 26
points in this game
take you back to one play that i thought
was really tough is in the second
quarter devonte adams has run a back
shoulder fade down on the goal line and
he's wide open and we've seen aaron
rodgers and devonte adams complete that
pass time and time and time again and
rogers puts it perfectly on his back hip
devonte opens up and he just dropped it
i don't know if it was a little too hot
on him or what it was but he just
dropped it and that set up back to back
really throws the devonta adams that
were incomplete one where he's just out
of the back of the end zone and one
where his incomplete over to the right
sideline but that was the play they had
a chance to tie it up right there even
the field they weren't able to do that
and this is one of the best red zone
offenses in football that wasn't able to
score touchdowns and why was that when
you were sitting there watching the game
what did you think it was they took away
to make it so tough
wait let's let's let's really i mean
shouldn't we focus on the plate of the
fourth down why didn't he go for it
let's focus on why matt lafleur did not
go for it because the other stuff that
you're talking about is important but
this is the most important decision on
the field and why matt um leflore didn't
go for it i was very disappointed i was
surprised i'm like i know they're going
to go forward they got aaron rodgers and
you look up and he goes and he sends a
field goal unit out and you got tom
brady um on offense and you're asking
your defense to stop tom brady i just i
didn't like the call i thought it showed
his inexperience i show i think it
showed his youth and
you have aaron rodgers and you guys have
built up a rapport a relationship a
professional trust and aaron rodgers is
waiting for that very moment you have to
give him the ability to go up in there
and try to score and even if he doesn't
score guess what they're on the eight
yard line so now tom has to go 92 yards
to score a touchdown i just
i didn't like it it just showed his
inexperience as a head coach and he's
going to regret that the entire
offseason and i don't know what's going
to happen to aaron rodgers but if i'm
rogers i'm looking at matt lafleur like
you didn't trust me in the most critical
moment of our season you did not trust
me and that would really bother me if i
if i were aaron rodgers
you get conservative you lose welcome to
the nfl playoffs it's as simple as that
and especially when you're going up
against tom brady or sean mcdermott
going up against patrick mahomes that
that's what it is i mean you get
conservative and you lose and in that
situation where you have aaron rodgers
from the eight yard line probably more
importantly knowing that you were going
to k if you kick that field goal okay
you cut it to five it's an eight point
game that's probably why he made the
decision if it was seven i'd like to
think there's no way he does it really
like i think there's no way he does it
with an eight-point game
but to kick it back to tom brady who his
entire career maybe what he's known best
for is never giving the ball back to an
offense in that situation he hits it
with an opportunity to put a game away
he puts people away it's keep away so
let's hear from coach as we always do if
we're going to bash when we let him in
on the conversation here's coach lefleur
on why he made the decision to not go
for it on that fourth down and eight
from the goal
it was just the circumstances of having
three shots
and
coming away with no yards
and knowing that you not only need the
touchdown but you need the two point so
the way i was looking at it was
we essentially had four timeouts
with the two minute warning
and
you know we we knew we needed to get a
stop and i thought we were gonna have a
stop there at the end but you know they
we got cold for for the pi
um
and
it didn't work out so
i think any time something doesn't work
out
do you regret it sure
but
we're always going to be process driven
here and the way our defense was
battling the way our defense was playing
felt like it was the right decision to
do and
it just didn't work out
i understand thinking about two minutes
with uh all of our timeouts but
yeah that wasn't my decision
i couldn't believe it honestly because
there's no guarantee that they're gonna
make it back down there again even if
they was on fourth down they might as
well
try but uh i know uh offense pretty
they've been amazing in four-minute
offense this year not giving the team
back the ball so i had all the utmost
confidence in them but
uh i know they if he could take it back
he probably who wouldn't do that next
time but i appreciate it offense did
that job we did our job and we came up
with the one
and if i'm aaron rodgers i am i am
furious and i'm sure he's at home and he
is furious because you mean to tell me
you think you got a better chance
kicking a field goal putting that
defense back on the field against the
greatest quarterback of all time the
much the most clutch quarterback of all
time as opposed to giving it to my
all-star all-pro
quarterback for an opportunity to score
a touchdown come on jack is
is that inexperienced is that an excuse
what do you read from what he's saying
i think experience specifically at the
coaching spot is one of the greatest
stories of championship weekend you saw
it with sean mcdermott who's been
phenomenal all year he's been phenomenal
to get buffalo into this position he got
him there by i mean they're nine nine
for eleven on fourth down nine for
eleven this year on fourth down it's a
big reason they have the record they
have a big reason they made it this far
and josh allen's a big reason why
they're able to convert those four downs
because he can run he can throw he's so
hard to bring down in the backfield he's
a big physical tight end body playing
the quarterback spot but both of those
inexperienced coaches i thought just got
a little soft and by a little soft i
mean very soft and key moments of those
games and i think when you haven't been
to many moments like that that you just
are not quite as trigger happy to go
make the risky play but if you don't
make the risky play i think it really is
more risky by not being risky if that
makes any sense i think it's more risky
when you're going up against tom brady
when you're going up against patrick
mahomes by playing soccer but they and i
thought they just played soft and that's
how you lose
jack they've been they've been they've
been risky all year they've been doing
it all year they dropped back
exactly and that's the thing with me and
that's why you could tell from aaron
rodgers his conversation that he's
trying to be humble he's trying to say
the right thing but at the end of the
day he wants to say i'm aaron rodgers
how do you not give me the ball how do
you not give aaron rodgers the ball
how do you not do that
and then and see this is the thing that
really bothers me and it bothered me
against doug peterson when doug peterson
came out and he talked lied about
putting um nate's sub phil in well when
you go back and you tell that same lie
to your locker room guess what happens
they don't believe you and then when the
owner comes down and he grabs four or
five guys and he says okay what do you
think about this that and the other all
the guys say the same thing i can't
trust him he lied to the locker room and
that's the reason part of the reason why
doug peterson got fired that's part of
the reason and and for just for the life
of me if i was matt lafleur i would call
aaron rodgers and say you know what i
messed up i messed up i made a i made a
terrible call i messed up and i just
think that you gain more respect from
your locker room and your quarterback if
you just come out and say you know what
i made a huge mistake i should have blah
blah blah but at the end of the day
everybody's so caught up in analytics
and what the analytics say as a court as
a head coach you should have a feel for
the game you should know this is my
quarterback this is the guy that i see
every day i see him practicing i see the
way he prepares i see how late he stays
i see how early he stays but yet you
would not give aaron rodgers the ball
matt lafleur he's wrong for that he's
absolutely wrong for that
well you could have given so let's say
you don't get it right right there right
so if you don't get it you're gonna
leave him the ball at what the set let's
assuming you gain zero yards on that
last play you're gonna leave tom brady
deep down in that territory and that at
least gives you a chance to get a tom
brady stop you kick a field goal you
bring him all the way out to the 25 yard
line you let him go to work operating
that offense it was just there just was
no logic in the decision and to be
honest with you i think it may wind up
being one of the biggest coaching heirs
of lefleur's career and i think that
they've had multiple of those this year
in terms of just not letting aaron
rodgers be involved in enough decision
making and it's ultimately led to him
feeling like he's a bit of an outsider
and him feeling like he's a bit of an
outsider i believe is the reason why
rogers is going to leave i think he's
going to try to do everything in his
power to get out of green bay this
offseason because i just don't think he
wants to finish his career there anymore
i think you know every time we see
somebody draft the heir apparent the
next guy who's going to be the future
quarterback it always winds up that that
quarterback winds up leaving town that's
just how it plays out and my guess now
is that aaron rodgers is going to try to
do the exact same thing it all started
back when they tried to go ahead and
take his replacement love in the first
round got him completely off guard they
follow it up by taking a power running
back and aj dylan that was no factor at
all all season long on a team that last
year was in the championship game they
were one game away from going to the
super bowl this is a ready now roster
and you go pick for the future that
right there is going to take off the
future your franchise or really forget
about the future franchise the current
state of your franchise right and aaron
rodgers here was rogers after the game
and he didn't sound very happy when he
started talking about the future sounded
like it might not be in green bay
wisconsin
what did this particular team mean to
you at this point in your career
yeah they're all special for sure i
think this one
as much as any of them i just found some
really
uh special friendships
with
you know
mercedes
and devonte
especially tim and i have become really
close over the years
jamal i loved him all
um aaron jones
a lot of guys futures
that are
you know uncertain you know myself
included
[Music]
that's what's sad about it most
i'm getting this far
obviously there's going to be an end to
it at some point whether we
make it past this one or not but
just the uncertainties he's tough and
the
finality of it all
last one bill huber
yeah it's kind of along those lines um
this is probably a better question for
next week but we might not get you next
week so
so how do you go on from here i mean you
can just hit on some of the realities a
minute ago so how do you go on from here
how do you how do you take the next step
yeah bill that's a good question i i
don't know i really don't uh
there's a lot of unknowns going into
this off season now
and
they're just i'm gonna have to take some
time away for sure and and
clear my head and
just kind of see what's going on with
everything
but it's uh
it's pretty tough right now especially
thinking about the guys that may or may
not be here next year
there's always change as to only
constant in this business
it's really tough to get to this point
really really tough
especially with it only being one
by week
in the playoffs
it's a grind just to get to this point
and that makes the finality of it all
kind of hits you like a ton of bricks
that's why it's a
gutting feeling
in your stomach
but i do appreciate
you all on the job that you've done this
year i appreciate our interactions
appreciate the opportunity to share
every week and
always be thankful for this season
and
and jack that is a guy that is
that gave everything he absolutely gave
everything you could tell how tired and
how dejected he is and if i'm aaron
rodgers and if if
just kind of knowing his situation and
if the packers can't come to me
and say this off season you know what
aaron you are our quarterback we made a
mistake you are a quarterback we want
you here for the next two or three years
you are our guy if they can't do that i
would try to force my way out of town
because
you know the guy has done so much for
that organization and for them not to
involve him for them not to communicate
for them all the things that you talked
about going out drafting and running
back and the quarterback and those
things and not really helping them out
in the passing game if i were aaron
rodgers and he
let me just say this aaron
when i left my first team i went and won
back-to-back super bowl rings so it
could be done it's not like just because
you're tied in with the packers that you
have to spend the rest of your career
it's okay to leave you should leave you
should go experience what free agency
about is about and what other teams are
willing to do and compromise for you and
how much other people may appreciate you
because to me it just doesn't seem like
the green bay packers appreciate your
greatness and everything that you've
done
i i would say this jack
when i look at aaron rodgers career
if he doesn't win that second super bowl
there's going to be a lot of question
marks surrounding aaron rodgers because
we talk about how great of a quarterback
is is he the greatest of all time no
he's one of the best athletic
quarterbacks um but he is not the
greatest of all time but at the same
time if you're green bay you have this
great quarterback here
you have to take care of them and if i'm
aaron rodgers if they can't come to me
and show me a little love and respect
i'm forcing my way out of town your
thoughts
totally i mean you talk about going
somewhere else and winning look no
further than tom brady he did it in one
year
one year he did it in the worst possible
offseason too
i mean one year is what it took there
was no preseason there was no ability to
get together with teammates before
preseason and just work on timing and
such he brings in antonio brown recruits
any old head around the league that he
possibly could to come down to tampa i
mean look at the way that that group on
the field after that game
reacted and responded to tom brady when
he walked up to the mic
it was unbelievable that's the kind of
teammate that tom brady is and i think
aaron rodgers has some of those same
effects but back to the point rodney we
were talking about with these becoming
sort of all-star teams when you look at
the chiefs roster from an offensive
weapon perspective then you look at the
bucks and this all all-star team over on
the nfc side and then look at green bay
look at what aaron rodgers has i mean
when he's throwing to devonta adams
three times in a row with the goal line
because he has nobody else not to
mention his tight ends are just okay i
mean tonya had a big year coming on i
don't know if he has this kind in a year
if it wasn't for aaron rodgers playing
quarterback for him i mean every time
he's in trouble he's looking to force
something to devonte adams and it's
because he has no number two marquez
scaling you never know what kind of game
you're gonna get him you're a great one
you get a bad one you just never know no
first round picks no first round picks
at wide receiver to give this man some
help i'm getting out and i don't think
it matters anymore that you have a few
years left on your contract i just don't
think it matters look at watson you know
look at what the nfl has become the
player at quarterback has so much power
so much leverage over the franchise if
he just sits his butt out they're gonna
have to they're gonna have to move
they're gonna have to move on to love i
don't think they want to do it but i
think they've forced his hand into
having to do it i think he doesn't want
to live in green bay wisconsin anymore
you got that big mansion in southern
california he loves being in san
francisco california and i think both of
those places are circling through his
brain right now
yeah i was just thinking la i was
thinking if you put aaron rodgers in a
raiders uniform if you put them in a
chargers uniform or a san francisco 49er
uniform
they're in the playoffs
they're in the playoffs i don't care how
many injuries they're in the playoffs if
you give them aaron rodgers
trust me green bay if you want to go and
rebuild with the young quarterback go
ahead trust me it's no fun all you have
to do is look at my patriots okay and
they had a veteran quarterback that went
to the super bowl and pro bowl um it's
if you can't appreciate aaron rodgers
man trust me there's 28 other teams that
would love to have aaron rodgers period
and i'm i'm i'm not even i'm done
talking about it
so leave it at that leave it at that
because you you would have thought they
would involve them in the head coaching
higher too i mean all of those things
you just would have thought he was a
part of and he never felt like he was
and and by the same respect
when i was sitting there watching that
game yesterday with tom brady i'm going
were 31 franchises shoot 32 other than
probably patrick mahomes how were 31
other franchises not lining up and doing
every every brinks truck everything they
could to go recruit tom brady this
offseason from what i heard by the end
of it it basically came down to tampa i
mean it basically was tampa and so yeah
he went to tampa and he takes tampa
straight to the super bowl but how was
every franchise in the nfl not doing
everything in their power to go get tom
brady to come this guy's still playing
like he's in his prime at 43 years old
is he not
yeah he's he does a wonderful job of
taking care of his body and doing all
the right things but this was a great
fit him and aryans they kind of bumped
heads initially and then throughout the
season i thought what you saw was bruce
arians taking one or two steps back and
letting tom communicate more with byron
left with somebody that's closer to his
age somebody that knows him a little bit
better um but yeah i just hey
it is what it is at this point in time
let's just see what happens at the game
but man aaron rodgers that's a bad dude
regardless i i don't care how how much
um they don't value him
yeah there we saw four bad dudes on
championship weekend this year
josh allen the homes that that's what
was so great about watching all these
quarter i mean these guys are
unbelievable
and i think tom brady you made a great
point there we'll move it to the chiefs
but i think tom brady he's one of the
few players like maybe and i'm talking
all those sports maybe lebron james too
but this just transcends coaching he has
the ability he's been around so many
coaches he's been in the league so many
years that he's at a point now where he
sees the game as a coach at the
quarterback position and he can elevate
everybody around him and lebron does
that same thing on the court i can't
think of anybody else that's in that
kind of a category maybe mahomes gets
there go ahead rodney do you see it that
same way
i i look at tom and just being a
teammate of his
the one thing that i know about tom is
tom treats everybody really really good
and he he gets the respect of the locker
room he truly gets the respect of the
locker room so yeah you'll see him
talking to a veteran player over there
but he's still gonna come over here and
talk to this guy over here i mean he
just
he's just a guy that everybody likes
he's no nonsense he's very honest he's
not full of a bunch of bs he's straight
to the point and his expectation is and
he will jump on you if if everybody else
is doing it 100 and focused and prepared
we expect you to be the same way it's
just the leadership it's the mental
toughness you think about
how difficult it is for a man like tom
brady switching teams trying to get to
know all his individual teammates trying
to get to ball to mike evans and antonio
brown guys that have had a plethora of
success in their lives and their
football lives and just everything that
it encompasses and going to a new city
and taking that team all throughout all
the ups and downs and to get to the
super bowl it's one of the greatest
achievements if not the greatest
achievement that i've seen in all of
team sports at 43 years old who does
that jack who does that it's just
incredible it's amazing this and this is
a guy
dude i've i've watched him come in the
weight room at five o'clock in the
morning and take care of his body and
get massages where everybody else is
gone he's still in there
and to think at 43 years old that he is
going to the super bowl i i just i can't
believe it
i just can't believe it man
and it may not be the last one he takes
them to
that's the craziest part i guess maybe
the first one he takes the bucks too
he might have a couple more runs in him
i mean it's true especially you get
aaron rodgers out of the nfc you get
drew brees out of the nfc
who the hell is left i mean he may
turn this thing into a little dynasty
down there in tampa i mean it's
unbelievable so the only other team that
really is keeping this thing interesting
is patrick mahomes the kansas city
chiefs the bills were by far the second
best team in the afc when you watch them
play on the same field as the chiefs
what's running through your mind
man listen i've had a tumultuous
relationship with the bills mafia but i
just got to give them props man they did
a heck of a job you know winning the
division which the patriots dominated
for so many years josh allen is an
absolute stud mcdermott all those guys
leslie frazier he did a wonderful job
with the defense
they just basically they were the
mercedes of the afc
and kansas city is that bentley the
rolls-royce it's just two different
classes of teams man you know you see
you know josh and josh and these guys
they're going to be good they're going
to continue to get better they're going
to add a couple more pieces offensively
and you know and in order to them to get
take that next step to go to the super
bowl they're gonna have to try to find a
running back a lot better running backs
than what they have they got two guys
and they're both average they're both
average running if they don't commit to
the running of football it's gonna be
josh allen like russell wilson running
around trying to create everything you
have to have a run game and that defense
is good enough to build on they still
got some people they need to sign but
that's a very good defense so they have
a really great foundation and and the
only team that really
i look at yes the mommy dolphins let's
see what happens with the patriots in
the division but i don't even look at
the jets as a as any type of threat so i
think this is a team that could really
dominate the division like the patriots
did if they just continue to do what
they've been doing
yeah i i love your point about the
running backs get some dynamic running
back in there you know preferably one we
can catch the ball too that josh allen
can start to establish a little bit of
that where you can throw it to somebody
they also need another wide receiver i
mean if
these are the shootout games that it's
going to take in a tight end and a great
tight end if these are the shootout
games it's going to take to make the
super bowl like in my opinion that's
what brady realized he's looking at andy
reid he's looking at the chiefs he's
going
i know for a fact i can't do anything
here in new england i have nothing i
have to go to an all-star team too if i
want to have a chance of competing with
them and you saw the bills go get stefan
diggs one of the great pickups of this
entire offseason he played like it i
mean right away clicked with the
quarterback had one of the biggest years
we've seen from a receiver he was
awesome ever this year right but who's
their number two i mean you know cole
beasley is a great slot guy he's tough
as nails and he he does a lot of things
great but he was hurt
somebody else he was
yeah he was hurt he was dealing with
some ankle problems in the slot i know
what you're saying they have the young
um kid gabriel on the outside but they
do need a really good number two john
brown he's he's not it um
no you're right they
yeah yeah they do
it's just what is becoming what the nfl
is right now so so for patrick mahomes
listen he's the guy that's built this
damn thing he's going back to the super
bowl two years in a row and they don't
look like they're slowing down they look
like they're speeding up at this point
so let's hear from the homes on super
bowl trip number two
i mean the super bowl is the super bowl
being able to go up against one of the
one of the greatest not the greatest
quarterback of all time
in his 150th super bowl i mean it's
going to be a great experience for me i
mean to go out there and get to have a
chance to repeat and get to do it
against the best i mean it's uh it's
something special and i'm excited for
the opportunity
and i'll tell you this man this this is
truly bragging rights just think
everybody's saying that patrick mahome
is the next just the greatest
quarterback to ever come out and if tom
brady beats him that's something that
tom is going to be able to carry into
retirement the rest of his life that is
huge but if he loses to patrick mahomes
and the chiefs trust me he's going to
take that very personally so tom he
wants to win this game and i you know
i've called thoma thug i look at patrick
mahomes that dude he doesn't play around
everything that he does is based off he
wants to win football games
it's gonna be an awesome super bowl i
can't wait
let's be honest man we all knew what had
to come down to this we we all knew as
much as all the other story lines around
the nfl were cute and fun and we bounced
them around for a few months we all knew
that the past you know what the nfl has
been for the last two decades and what
the nfl is gonna be for the next two
decades had to at some point me and how
could it be any better than for the
bucks hosting their first the first time
we've ever seen a team host a home super
bowl for this to be the moment right
when he gets down there to tampa it is
just it's perfect there could not be a
better super bowl this season and
patrick mahomes in my opinion is just
getting so much better i mean you're
putting just this talent that we haven't
really seen maybe aaron rodgers is close
from just a god-given talent scale point
you know to what we're seeing skill
point as we're seeing from mahones right
now it's probably about as close as
we've seen but i don't know that we've
seen what what patrick can do like i
think he may even be another level but
now that the mind is coming with that
and andy rita has another season with
him the relationship that he has with
travis kelsey like we all have that one
friend growing up that knows what we're
thinking better than we know what we're
thinking ourselves we all have that one
guy when you play high school sports
when you play on the playground with
them they're just doing things and ahead
of you know before you can even tell
them to go there they're already there
that's what's happening on the football
field with kelsey and with patrick
mahomes
they're both so smart i mean to think
that you know travis kelsey almost never
made it to this point his career like
brian kelly and jason kelsey had to go
get him to the university of cincinnati
after he got caught smoking dope it for
him to make it to this point in his
career and now to be here paired up with
mahomes and andy reed i just think that
relationship we haven't even gotten to
tyrek hill i mean there is so many great
relationships and partnerships and the
same leader that tom brady is patrick
mahomes is the younger version of that
these dudes love patrick mahomes
absolutely man he's he's a humble leader
he works his butt off he always he's
very inclusive when he talks about his
teammates um he never makes it about him
and it's always team so when i look at
when i listen to patrick mahomes
and i remember the speeches and the
conversations and just the way tom um
brady carried himself they're very
similar they are very similar they are
born leaders and you just see the poise
and you see the poise when they're under
pressure when they're under duress
whether it's in the game on the sideline
you just see them and yeah sometimes
they they go off and they yell and
scream at their teammates but for the
most part they're bringing their guys in
trying to figure out a way and it's just
it's it's so rare man i'm telling i
played with brian leaf and he was
drafted first or second in 1998 and to
be able to play with the biggest bust in
nfl history and to be able to play with
the greatest quarterback of all time
it's two totally different two totally
different just directions tom he does
everything right he works out he lifts
he involves his teammates he
communicates the other quarterback he
does what he wants to do and that's what
you see the difference and you know
these
these elite quarterbacks compared to
these guys are just just average
quarterbacks
and also with tyreke hill like i think
you know given that he has patrick
mahomes and given that he has andy reid
we may have the number one wide receiver
in football conversation too often
without bringing up his name right away
he turned two plays two plays yesterday
i want to talk about for just a second
one was a three yard out that he busted
for about a 50 yarder i have no clue how
i mean he just turned it into a punt
return made the whole defense miss and
gained 40 yards the other one was a
slant that he took for about 80.
those two plays so it's two plays where
he has no chance to really get more than
about seven and he gets over a hundred
yards by himself
there's no way that you can you can put
the value on that like who else does
that in football besides tyreek hill who
else you talk about the great ones dk
metcalf or julio jones nobody can just
make the entire defense miss like tyreek
hill and then you put some of the route
running stuff he does i mean that 15
yard out he ran for the big first down
it was like he creates seven yards of
separation he's some of the best
defenders in the world that are looking
at him going i have no clue which
direction he's going to go or how fast
he's going to get there he's a joystick
i mean they have no clue how to defend
him and when they can't figure that out
i mean they're playing without sami
watkins they're playing without sami
watkins yesterday and in the first
quarter i forgot about it i just forgot
about it nicole hardman tyree kill it's
just endless the weapons are endless uh
and that's that's the super bowl that
we're headed towards so it's so awesome
fired up about what this is and what
it's become how we got here go ahead you
got something to say rod
no i was gonna say miko hartman i was
really impressed with him a young guy
that made that critical mistake on the
goal line dropping that punt but andy
reid trusted him came back to him and he
made up for it it's little things like
that you talk about tyreek hill you talk
about travis kelsey travis kelsey i
played against some of the best tight
ends to ever play in the national
football league and tony gonzalez all
them dudes antonio gates jason whitten
all those dudes nobody runs a better
route that i've ever seen than just the
route running than travis kelsey he is
the best route running tight end that
i've ever seen i just i've never seen a
guy that can stop on a dime you put a
corner back on him he's pushing him to
the side he's too small you put a safety
there too slow a linebacker he's just
too athletic it's just amazing what this
young man has been able to accomplish
and tyreke hill you're absolutely right
we look at him as this little jitterbug
and you know he could just we don't
really respect him for his skill as a
wide receiver
i guess there's a difference between the
most dangerous wide receiver
and the best wide receiver do you do you
see do you see a like a difference
between who's the best and who's the
most dangerous wide receiver because i
think tyreek hill is the most dangerous
wide receiver
yeah i i well personally i don't because
i think there's that answer the most
dangerous wide receivers tyree kill and
the best wife
i think it's as simple as that he takes
the top off the defense better than
anybody i think he runs routes better
than anybody i just don't think people
could stay with him and he gets
disrespected because he's short i think
it's it's
that his simple yeah is that let's
speaking of short you got you see this
baby yoda by the way rodney you catch
this little baby yoda tweet on the way
out i know we got to hit a little break
too but get a look at this
brady
[Laughter]
he got the baby against the old man hey
it's a beautiful thing it is poetic
motion and we're moving into tampa for
the super bowl safety blitz coming right
back
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports